what are the best qualities slash skills
a person needs to be a great soldier
slash fighter and are these the same
i think that there are some qualities in
each
that complement each other um
for example the regimented schedule of
the military
does good things for somebody that wants
to aspire to be a fighter because most
fighters are selfish little pricks
that are super lazy and they don't
understand what it takes
dedication wise to little things like
setting your alarm being on time to work
out writing a journal as to what you're
eating
um not chasing [ __ ] all night long and
that you should go to bed
like those that that's discipline that's
that's what that is that's that word
um and a lot of military not all guys
but a lot of the military
teaches discipline so that is a
characteristic
that would complement somebody that
aspires to be a fighter
um and then fighters you know like yes
obviously you're learning skills
technical skills that could be
life-saving
um you know it's like you get
comfortable with sweating you're getting
used to hard work and you know so some
of those things are nice
but um yeah so there's some things that
that do well i think being a good
soldier can make you a better fighter
and some things about being a good
fighter can make you a better soldier
so yeah yeah i think uh for me the the
biggest
quality that would transfer both back
and forth
soldier fighter and i'll go ahead and
throw one more on there and that's being
in a leadership position
but to me it's humility
and i think what makes a soldier a
fighter a leader
the most important quality that they can
have is humility because
the minute that you're not humble is the
minute that you stop
training as hard as you can it's the
minute you say you know what i don't
need to do that extra workout today
that's a lack of humility because you're
thinking i already got this i got this
in the bag
from a leadership position same thing i
don't need to train my guys hard i don't
need to show up earlier than my guys
because they already respect me no you
need to earn that respect
every day and so for me
always humility is the most important
characteristic of a person because
you're not also not learning
once you're not humble i don't need to i
don't need to roll today i don't need to
hold i'm gonna need to get on the pads
today
i don't need to swing that kettlebell
today i'm already good
get humble get humble or you're gonna
get humbled
dude boom that's a raindrop shirt
sorry let me let me put this in my phone
real fast it'll be recorded too
you can refer back i don't want you to
keep it i want to keep it
we got all kinds of t-shirt sayings that
come out of the podcast each time
be humble or get humbled take the high
road or the high road and take you
yeah that's another good one
saved okay
all right that's humility right there
laughs right like learning from external
it's also thievery of his um
intellectual property but
i didn't trade marker yet i'm sure
you'll cut me a giant
fat check for the thousands and
thousands of t-shirts that get sold with
that on it